why blockbuster they've latest and
greatest in videogames with an adult
blockbuster membership you can rank Game
Boy Advance games like Super Mario
advance with an e rating blockbuster are
you game enough well guys in case you
didn't know the last blockbuster store
officially closed it is a sad day for us
movie fans and believe it or not the
very last title rented was apparently
this is the end that's it's bittersweet
and a good movie also it got me thinking
about blockbuster and a buddy of mine
Jake Baldino from his channel because
video games made a video all about
Blockbuster and I was thinking about it
too and I saw his video and that made me
think more about it
and I realized I have so many nostalgic
memories about movie stores and rental
stores going there to rent video games
or movies and I kind of want to do a
little bit of a blockbuster eulogy if
you may there's also a few other stores
I'm going to talk about that aren't
around anymore largely because of the
rise of Netflix and various things like
that where you can just have it sent
straight to your home or instantly
stream to your computer or ps3 or
whatever it is that you have and that's
pretty cool I have a Netflix account
myself I use it very often but there is
a novelty of going to a store like
Blockbuster or the old-time Hollywood
video and actually picking up a case and
examining it and saying wow I actually
really want to see this because this
artwork is awesome or because they're
all these little critics ratings that
probably don't mean anything at all but
they all like it so I should watch it
right I always would play video games
with my friends at their houses but I
never had my own system into the
Nintendo 64 and I kind of have
blockbuster to thank for introducing me
to that so I went out to a location that
actually used to be a blockbuster and I
recorded some footage enjoy so right
here is a relic of the past this is the
old blockbuster video that I used to go
to when I was a kid that's where I
discovered intento 64 I would go here on
Fridays with my allowance and hope to
find a pre played game really cheap and
pick it up
I discovered Star Fox 64 in there it had
a TV setup with the controller you could
hold it and you could play the game
right there and that's where it all
started for me I was hooked from then I
used to go here and rent VHS tapes with
my mom on the weekends we'd get like
chicken and
fries and hot sauce and it sounds like a
horrible combination but it's actually
really good and we'd watch movies and it
was awesome I loved it here and I kind
of missed that to be honest
check this out this is my blockbuster
membership card I still have this thing
look at this thing 1996 I got this thing
that's what it says in the bag June 1st
1996 my blockbuster membership card I
was a young boy I still have it and I'm
gonna keep it forever because it's
nostalgic it's special look it's my
blockbuster card I would go there and I
would rent all the newest games and that
was one of the great things about these
kind of stores was that you could rent a
game instead of pay 4050 or now $60 to
buy a game you could actually go and
rent a game and have it for a week and
enjoy and it was only like $4.99 back in
the day there are still a few chains
around me that are open one called
family video that I still go to on a
regular basis on the East Coast that's
pretty successful and they still rent
games and you rent movies and so I can
actually still kind of enjoy the rental
store experience in that way now as I
mentioned in that footage I would go to
Blockbuster and I would peruse their
pre-owned games section because I got
like $20 for my allowance like every two
weeks or something when I was a kid yeah
it's actually not too bad for a kid in
school but my parents were awesome they
had a lot of Nintendo 64 games that were
like $19.99 and my parents were like
sure you can have that one will cover
the tax this is all the ones I got
cruisin USA back in the day I still have
the original case for it and on the back
it does say Blockbuster Video and so
yeah this is one of the games I got back
in the day I don't know what it is about
it it's just special like the idea of
going to a store like that and actually
going like I want to play this because
this looks cool this is not the original
case for battle for Naboo this is
actually a collector's case that I
picked up but the actual game is
property of Blockbuster Video that's
kind of annoying that those tacky
stickers are on there but I like kind of
leave it on there just purely for a
nostalgic purposes I remember I would
specifically go to stores like
Blockbuster and Hollywood Video to rent
really stupid movies or cheesy movies or
children's films that my friends and I
found entertaining we would have like
Friday night parties together we would
purposely go out on the hunt for
something stupid or entertaining in that
way
you know what I mean we picked up VHS
tapes there all the time one of the ones
that I frequently rented was goosebumps
the werewolf of fever swamp I've had
this thing forever and Hollywood video
in particular had a fantastic section of
anime VHS for 99 cents you could rent
like all these older obscure animes like
from the late 80s and early 90s one of
the ones I specifically remember renting
there was this anime called they were 11
it was like these people were on a ship
and they didn't know I was going on
there was some sort of thing happening
people were disappearing it was really
cool it's actually on YouTube right now
I feel like watching that again but I
will never forget going inside
blockbuster they had a TV set up in
there they had an n64 controller I
grabbed it I discovered starfox 64 I got
my own antenna 60 for the first game I
got with Star Fox because of Blockbuster
I would go there frequently I got Star
Wars Rogue Squadron there for 1999 I
vividly remember that there were so many
good memories for me with Blockbuster
and hollywood video or i would go there
and i would find things that became
important to me in my life you know
video games that I played and loved and
it's not just the game itself that I
look back on and think wow that was a
really fun game it's really the time
around that game or that movie from my
youth where I connect that to that time
period in my life and then I think about
how cool that was and it wasn't just the
game or the movie itself that makes me
feel good about that kind of time it's
the things that came with it the time
with my friends going there Friday and
Saturday nights and just spending hours
perusing through blockbuster and
Hollywood video a lot of fun it sucks
that it's gone rest in peace blockbuster
you gave me a lot of good memories and
thank you for that I still have my
blockbuster card though there's always
that my blockbuster card Chris Duckman
blockbuster card I'll sign it and it'll
be worth like $2 yeah I'd like to know
do you guys have any memories related to
Hollywood video or blockbuster or family
video or any video store that you would
go and rent movies or games or whatever
also what I'd like to know if you have
any still around you like I do
a few and it's kind of nice to be able
to still do that and I know a lot of
people don't because I've mentioned in
videos that I rented something I've
gotten comments from people who are like
where do you rent things there are still
some places out there they exist as
always thanks very much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my next